all right man cheering bro cheers one
two three
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everybody season three we're
back tacos contodo we're here in an
exclusive backyard seafood oasis
underground 106 in the city of lenox a
big shout out to la taco it should come
to no surprise that some of the best
food in los angeles comes from a
backyard i'm talking ceviche
camaron tacos and marlene etc etc you
can find them
right over here
we're meeting with none other than stevo
you might know him from jackass you
might know him from his stunts his
podcast
you might know him from touring he does
stand up he does it all and we got my
big homie
churro churro what's up camera's over
here buddy
and uh churro's excited he wants to go
eat shrimp those aren't shrimp those are
mosquitoes floating in the water that's
all right
we are conveniently located in the
flight path of airplanes right by lax
airport
so if you don't
seafood
[Music]
you got that right steve well hurry up
i'm hungry man
[Music]
no i hear you i you know churro this is
churro decided to wear a neck pillow
heard we were going to be by the airport
and
look what he did
thanks for being here man great to see
you really
one of my favorite comics oh stop it
i've always told you that though thanks
man yeah this is uh yeah this is super
exciting we got a a great meal ahead of
us i know you like seafood so we're
gonna yeah i [ __ ] with seaford i brought
uh
oh
[Music]
this sprinter van i mean it looks like
you've had some uh run-ins with some low
bridges
yeah i'm a bad driver i have my my
stevo's hot tubs for your butthole oh
nice and that's all i got to shoot i
meant to bring a little case steeple hot
sauce for your butthole because that's
the last place i want to put it i like
to put it on my food call me
old-fashioned but this is great can we
try some of this sure man sure awesome
let me show you around it's going to
blow your mind dude
churro you excited churra
man wendy doesn't know what she's
missing
dude this is a homie stevie i know what
he is exactly
what i'm saying
is this always here yeah dude sick how
did people find this place i mean you
know what
it started off just by like word to
mouth man
and then afterwards just instagram and
yeah pretty much it just started
building up like that epic what was like
the idea behind let's do it in our
backyard my dad yeah decided to do that
that's beautiful yeah and you brought
your son in to help you yeah yeah my
friend and my wife our family my
daughter is that hard working with
families
sometimes sometimes i used to work with
my dad my dad had a landscaping business
and man i was like
never employee of the month and it was
just me
company party sucked
no matter how much i helped my dad he
always thought i was lazy oh yeah yeah
yeah one time he told me if i was a if i
was a transformer i'd be a futon so
that's how lazy you are like me too
that's right
my name is
106 underground sergio penales junior
prep 106 see food on the ground
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
what i love about my job is
my fam is i see them hustling so it
makes me want to hustle hello
[Laughter]
oh wow look at this
got the marlin tacos
right here for you guys bro
look at this feast this is the last dish
right here for you guys
look at that enjoy we got your tortillas
right there you make tacos wow this is
lobster
yeah bro i'm telling you that's the
whole budget dude we got to eat this if
not i mean
i've had the pleasure of opening for you
it was so great to see you up there man
you're the best opener i ever had oh
[ __ ]
i got it on camera
i knew you weren't going to be an opener
for long because you were killing it so
much so you've done stand-up for 12
years right 11 of those you're touring
clubs now you're doing theaters do you
remember your first joke i did i totally
remember my first joke the first time i
ever did stand-up
i had no idea i was going to do stand-up
somebody invited me to a comedy club to
do a stunt on stage
and i showed up at the lap factory on
sunset i walked in and i'm like yeah i
wonder what stunt i'm gonna do right
looked at the stage i just saw what was
going on i said man trying to do that is
the [ __ ] craziest thing i could ever
try try to do yo i was like dude i'm
gonna just try and
make people laugh by talking
it was so scary i walked on the stage
and said hey everybody
i'm in the mood for a [ __ ]
does anybody want one i did i got a
laugh right boom mister yeah i got it i
got a lap and i was so happy
i spent less than three minutes on that
stage i got the [ __ ] out of there before
i blew it
and um
and and i was still talked right away
some fishy chatronas ah dude i love it
i feel like you're one of the few
stand-up comics that
doesn't really need to exaggerate
because you lived it you're coming from
a very real place and that was the best
thing for my stand up like what like i'm
telling stories that are true
and with all the jokes in there what if
i edit the footage of the stories
happening and i'm like my head exploded
but for my third hour i'm like how do i
film new stuff that's crazier than ever
right and and that's what i did dude and
you elevated it to the oh my god the
next level i went and did [ __ ] that i
would never be allowed to do on jackass
because it's totally illegal
totally x-rated
i went nuts
like i got butt ass naked
had another man strapped to my back and
[ __ ] jacked up in an airplane
so i blew a load
simultaneously as i fell out of the
airplane sky jacking skyjack i had a
medical professional in disguise
administer stolen general anesthesia
drugs
into my [ __ ] vein while i'm hauling
ass on a bicycle wow i went
nuts what do you think of the seafood so
far yeah i'm loving it man the ceviche
the apple ceviche is off the hook the
aguachilas are insane
they're just so good try stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole i absolutely
will and that's going to be a stump for
me because i can't hang when it comes to
life yeah this one's not so hot the
other one the one that's so hot is
stevo's butthole destroyer hot sauce
destroyer hot sauce yeah you know what
it's in the name
look it just comes up oh
look at that this is a snook this is the
one i was telling you that jonathan gold
call them the snook whisperer this is
what they're known for right here sauce
it up dude
steve i was hot sauce for your butthole
man is that good or should i put more
that is great
that's great
yeah and the fish is out of this world
my girl said that if you ask me what my
favorite kind of taco is that i should
say sadly my girl couldn't be here okay
hilarious what is your favorite taco do
you have a favorite taco around town
yeah
unfortunately my girl is not here
natural second delivery to be clear like
i had an advantage going into stand-up
because people knew me from jackass but
i started touring in 2010 when jackass
3d was in theaters okay and i could not
[ __ ] sell out the smallest comedy
club nobody gave a [ __ ] about stevo
doing stand up and i didn't give up i
just kept grinding and kept grinding
i've found myself thinking this a lot
lately and and i seem
pretty intense but um i really believe
that intelligence is useful
talent
is helpful
but nothing touches enthusiasm when it
comes to
making things happen and bringing
meaning to your life just the other day
out of nowhere
some i heard somebody say
that
enthusiasm that i got goosebumps here
that it comes from the latin word en
theos which means with god
that's pretty cool
so when you're enthusiastic when you're
on fire for something when you're
passionate about something that's like
you're after you're an instrument a
vessel for god in the universe you know
what are you enthusiastic about
i mean i've always just wanted to be
known to be remembered now i think uh
i'm just trying to earn as much money as
i can so that i can uh
do do awesome stuff to help animals to
do you know like
i really am after building this big
property this this animal center
uh taking on the animal sanctuary i mean
dude i i i
beat that drum like crazy man and so
in the past i was just motivated to get
attention and so now it's like
you know let me uh like have a higher
goal wow
stevo is dropping the knowledge man
that's that's fire man i want to say
thank you so much i i i can't thank you
enough i mean also my 13 year old self
would not let me
live it down if i didn't do a
stunt with you i got i got you dog let
me get it stink knife dude the universe
brought us i'm gonna go get a knife i'll
be right back
i know this one and it's scary already
yeah yeah i mean you remember when we
were at the club together
i did like not middle-aged dude my eyes
went bad and
like i'm not used to taking off glasses
to balance a knife on my face
[Music]
it's getting it off and scary
thank you for watching this is season
three
here we go i get half and you get half
you know what we're going for yeah
there's the glasses
i used to do this on stage every night
sometimes twice a night and then we're
having clubs i'm already sweating all
right man shoot bro cheers one two three
oh
man
fresh repeats i'm always putting [ __ ] in
my eyes man
oh imagine if you had balls in your eyes
and they got kicked
oh man
yeah you're gonna have to give me a
second
you did that for every show yeah
i'm stevo and this is tacos con turdo
with jesus trejo
it's the lemon in my eyes
yeah i did
[Music]
hello my name is jesus i'm the host of
tacos contolo and don't forget to like
and subscribe you can watch more right
here hurry watch another episode before
your boss comes in and you get fired for
real this time